c'est notre premier panel politique de
l'année 2021 avec sébastien bovet hélène
buzzetti et christian dufour bonsoir et
bonne année à vous tous soit julie merci
en somme ça va commencer ray de demain
la nouvelle année quand je regardais
celle d'un point de presse annoncée du
premier ministre hugo à 11h15 on à
monsieur legault à 17 heures avec
monsieur à bouddha et monsieur dubé
sébastien il va rencontrer d'abord
monsieur legault les partis d'opposition
avant se présenter devant les
populations
est-ce que ça commence à sentir une
annonce de confinement ça commence à
sentir probablement une prolongation des
mesures qui sont en place en ce moment
peut-être à l'exception des écoles y est
philosophiquement on me dit qu'il ya une
volonté ferme au gouvernement de rouvrir
les écoles dit maintenant dans quelles
conditions exactement est ce qu'on va
faire une différence entre le primaire
et le secondaire
est-ce qu'on va avoir des mesures
additionnelles sanitaires dans les
écoles pour éviter les foyers de
contagion ou les éclosions
peut-être oui mais donc
philosophiquement on veut protéger les
écoles en vue que les enfants aillent à
l'école
physiquement pour ce qui est des
commerces à cause du constat ou des
statistiques actuelles de 1500 cas par
jour environ
il serait surprenant que les commerces
puissent rouvrir comme il l'était avant
noël christian on entend une experte un
petit peu plus tôt la qui était en
entrevue avec non madame bourges est
celle va dire on devrait même aller
comme en france avec un couvre-feu vous
pensez quoi se mesure comme ça moi je
suppose un expert sanitaire et je veux
dire qu'on attend beaucoup d'experts
center qui sont à peu près unanime en
nous disant qu' il faudrait il faudra
être plus strict construit les
restrictions donc j'ai l'impression que
c'est à ce à quoi il faut s'attendre
comme sebastian le dit avec peut-être
l'exception des écoles mais au delà de
la dynamique cnda faut quand même être
réaliste il ya tout le reste il ya toute
la dynamique de la santé psychologique
de l'homme et des libertés publiques de
l'économie et c'est très simple parce
que des gens les gens sont au bout de
leur rouleau le dossier là des voyageurs
qui sont allés dans le sud montrent que
y'a vraiment le phénomène du bouc
émissaire qui est en train d'émerger
dans toutes les périodes de crise de
l'humanité
où on sombrait dans l'impuissance les
angoisses la part ya toujours eu des
boucs émissaires à l'époque il la peste
noire au moyen âge c'était les juifs
c'était les femmes qu'on considérait
comme des sorcières je trouve que la
haine parce que le terme n'est pas trop
fort à l'égard des québécois qui ont une
valeur d'aller dans le sud est très
inquiétant parce que là dans la mesure
où dans les prochaines semaines on doit
s'attendre à ce que ce soit encore plus
strict à ce que les gens soient plus
malheureux plus craintifs
quelles vont être les nouveaux boucs
émissaires donc pour la dynamique center
je répète que je suis pas un expert
senneterre il ya tout le reste aussi
dans tifo paru hélène en fait j'ai
toujours dit c'est ça c'est qu'il ya
cette fatigue un moment donné quand les
gens deviennent un peu colérique
j'oserais ou un peu la méchante peu
courte qu'en réalité alors effectivement
le phénomène des boucs émissaires et
l'existant mais est-ce que la
responsabilité du gouvernement c'est
aussi la santé publique et parfois c'est
prendre des décisions qui sont très
impopulaires
s'ils sont dans une situation où tant
fédéral que provincial ils sont dans une
situation qui est vraiment pas facile
surtout rendu à ce moment ci de
l'histoire non c'est pas dit c'est pas
c'est pas du tout facile d'imposer ces
mesures je vais dire comme christian moi
non plus je ne suis pas une experte en
santé publique en mesure sanitaire mais
je me pose la question quand on parle
par exemple de confinement d'un
couvre-feu radical est ce que vraiment
ça n'y aurait des choses il semble que
le problème auquel on assiste et le
non-respect des règles actuelles donc
est ce que vraiment la solution passe
par se doter d'encore plus de règles ou
je ne sais pas comment on ferait ça mais
amener les gens à respecter davantage
les règles actuelles c'est clair en
voyant les statistiques sur le nombre de
contaminations comme le dit votre
spécialiste un peu plus tôt à l'émission
que pendant le temps des fêtes le 20 25
décembre
il ya eu des rassemblements les gens ont
triché il y en a eu beaucoup de ça il y
en a qui ont triché dans le sud est donc
et je suis pas certaine car en mettant
une couche supplémentaire savoir régler
les choses
peut-on par contre en prolongeant la
période compte tenu que l'on sera plus
en vacances comme on l'était au temps
des fêtes mais là on voit moins tricher
par la force des choses et peut-être
quand vint se confirmant là aurait un
effet les faits qu'on souhaitait
déjà qu'ils y sont obligés confiné mais
ça donne rien les chiffres continuent à
monter les associations savent on se
leurre allez-y que la motion a dit je
suis pas sûr que les gens est riche et à
ce point là durant les fêtes peut-être
un petit peu comme tel ce qu'on constate
c'est partout dans le monde on a
l'impression que la copie de prendre
d'expansion et de plus en plus
dangereuse
quelles que soient les mesures qui sont
appliquées et on est un peu dans une
famille qu'on dirait que c'est toujours
plus de restrictions comme si ces 100 m
dames des fuites ou d'amis fut donc si
les mesures de confinement avaient eu un
effet on nous avait été probablement
l'écouté vous voyez ça marche pour
continuer là on nous dit maintenant que
ça semble pas avoir eu d'effet donc il
faut continuer encore moi ce n'est pas
ça qui m'inquiète
en fait c'est pour ça que moi je répète
toujours qu'il faut pas s'en tenir à la
dynamique sanitaire parce que le reste
est énorme et important et je le répète
la haine à l'égard des québécois qui ont
exercé leur droit d'aller vers le sud
est profondément inquiet on sent
vraiment que cette facture sociale là
vous préoccupe beaucoup
sébastien un mot aussi là dessus parce
qu'ils ont si ce qui bloque le
gouvernement qui disent ben écoutez
comme ces experts l'accent sorties sont
plus de 300 qui disent bien vous tenez
pas compte des bonnes affaires vous
confondez aérosols la vaccination ça va
trop lentement
il y aussi sol oui il ya eu des valses
hésitations sur le masque du
gouvernement au départ seuls
scientifiquement s'était pas démontré
que savait c'était pertinent or on nous
a imposé une basque par la suite donc en
effet même gouvernement il jongle avec
douze balles en ce moment puis ils
essaient d'en échapper aucune mais c'est
sûr qu'il va en échappée certaine les
voyageurs par exemple je comprends la
colère de christian envers ceux qui ont
la haine envers les voyageurs
en même temps c'était peut dire de ne
pas voyager il ya des gens qui ont
exercé leur droit d'aller voyager mais
c'est comme si un ras-le-bol actuelle on
est comme un trop plein en ce moment de
2 d'émotion et de fatigue et les gens
donc ont la mèche courte ça excuse pas
qu'ils aient de la haine envers les
voyageurs qui ont exercé un droit légal
mais ça exprime un ras le bol
actuellement puis un besoin de d'essayer
de voir une lueur d'espoir villa lueur
d'espoir pour gouvernement c'est maxime
la vaccination mais en même temps c'est
un côté
négatif aussi c'est que les gens
peut-être relâché leurs gardes
de toute façon il va y avoir la
vaccination alors le gouvernement ait
pris là dedans il improvise un peu puis
parce que ya pas de mode d'emploi pour
combattre la coved
mais ce qui l'est c'est d'être c'est
cohérent des fois y'a pas nécessairement
toute la cohérence nécessaire mais il
essaie de conjuguer santé mentale
réussite scolaire par exemple et qu'on
maintienne d'économie et protection des
déjà contractés on va continuer à parler
des voyageurs mais des élus voyageurs
alors on a bien vu c'est devenu
pratiquement une chasse est l'élu qui
ont voyagé dans chacun des gouvernements
provinciaux et fédéral aussi ses piques
tonnant le nom qu'on est en train de
trouver en pierre arcand et youri
chassin
il y en a 5 du côté des vidéos fédéraux
écouter longe le chemin tout ce qu on en
est rendu du côté des algues vertes et
le gouvernement provincial
hélène on sait que bon c'est passé
faisait ça prendre la cohérence
oui mais ça prend aussi comment une
sorte d' exemplarité
ce qui n'a pas été et qu est ce que ça
vous étonne qu en ait eu autant d'élus
que ce soit permis de voyager dans temps
des fêtes
oui absolument je mettrais quand même un
petit bémol il ya certains des noms qui
sont sorties qui ont effectué leur
voyage quelque part en début septembre
nous en octobre quand le message était
quand même un peu mou ainsi trait sur la
question des voyages
il faut garder à l'esprit que quand on
calcule le nombre de députés kirk envoyé
dans chacune des provinces
ça frise les mails alors ça reste un
très petit nom mais oui vous avez raison
c'est frustrant parce que ce sont ces
personnes là qui nous disent de ne pas
voyager et qui le font à leur dos moi je
m'interroge quand même sur les
conséquences je pense par exemple à
monsieur harper sa cheffe savait qu'il
voulait faire ce voyage et ce n'est
seulement que lorsqu'il s'est fait
pincer parce que quelqu'un le vus là-bas
que le on nous annonçait des
conséquences mais comment se fait-il que
la chine n'est pas exercer son autorité
en amont entend écoute ce n'est pas
acceptable gènes par une conférence de
presse conjointe disant de ne pas leur
voyage
s'il le fait il y aura des conséquences
mais une chose avec d'autres fortes
il n'avait pas fait de menaces à ses
députés
il savait que son ministre des finances
aller là bas normands il a fini par
démissionner mais
bref et j'ai un peu l'impression qu'ils
sont innocents se fait papa et c'est on
le fait quand même et on gère après ce
qui ne montrent pour qu'ils les montrent
pas grand sens de responsabilité que ça
vaut mais je suis donc est ce qu'une
différence pour vous qui sont entre une
personne là quelqu'un autre travail peu
importe qui parle dans le sud et un élu
qui part dans le sud en pleine période
de confinement dans la deuxième vague
oui une science fondamentale parce que
la tolérance l'opinion publique à
l'égard des élus ou des personnages peu
de ce qu'ils voient dans le sud est nul
et on est en partie dans l'irrationnel
non parce que monsieur arcand est allé
quand même dans un endroit la barbade je
pense que des trois cols et puis est
allé dans sa résidence personnelle mais
aussi beaucoup d'hypocrisie
maintenant ça m'étonne pas qu'il ya des
gens qui sont dans le sud comme ça au
sein du personnel du personnel politique
c'est même révélateur que dans un très
grand nombre de corps des chefs de
partis étaient d'accord donc c'est comme
si maintenant les personnages politiques
sont au pays par le club des gens
dépassés par la rage de la population
parce que la population le transport
puis on ne peut pas parler le 10000
dollars pour l'édition donc j'irai que
trois niveaux en fait le citoyen
ordinaire bon l'élite ce qu'on appelle
les touristes à ta de façon très
méprisante
bon évidemment ça passe pas dans
l'opinion publique mais risque avait le
droit de le faire mais il reste quand au
personnel politique si c'était finale
quand on passe à me charles qui a été
démis aujourd'hui de ses responsabilités
on voit que les personnes bébés les
chefs de partis ont pas le choix
en fait il faut vraiment qu'ils
s'inclinent devant une opinion publique
qui leur avait reproché du tout ouais
est-ce que ça va différents le résultat
pour monsieur youri chassin sébastien
parce que lui aussi parti en voyage il
est allé au pérou mais dans son cas il
est allé retrouver un conjoint qui
n'avait pas vu depuis un an je pense
est-ce que ça on peut faire une
catégorie à part
zaba ce voyage le pour un policier s'est
permis mais pour monsieur arcand qui
s'en va dans une résidence secondaire
sur le nil dans le sud mais ça c'est pas
permis
j'ose à peine utilisé la phrase mise en
marché du voyage de monsieur chat sait
mais il a été présenté comme un voyage
presque humanitaire entre guillemets
parce qu'il allait rejoindre son
conjoint qui n'a pas vu depuis un an
alors que pierre arcand elle est pour
se retrouver avec sa famille ses petits
enfants donc il ya comme deux façons de
présenter la chose est en effet monsieur
arcand paie le prix alors que youri
chassin et pas grand monde qui demandent
des sanctions contre monsieur chassaing
peut-être qui en aura mais ça a été
autorisé par françois legault le premier
ministre du québec malgré l'interdiction
qui l'avait envoyé à ses députés de
voyager alors dans la façon de présenter
les choses c'est comme si on blâme
monsieur arcand qui a pourtant
semble-t-il respecter toutes les
consignes sanitaires à la barbade et
même avant d'y aller et on ne plante pas
eu les chasser comme dans l'esprit de
certains libéraux disons qu'il ya deux
poids deux mesures on verra si monsieur
legault est pas forcé de réagir parce
que madame anglade a sanctionné
violences ont dit exactement et moi
j'agis trail alors on va y aller avec
alain nguyen huy j'ajouterai quand même
seulement à ce que dans la population
générale
il ya des gens qui se trouvent dans des
situations similaires qu'ils attendent
un proche qui est à l'étranger qui
attend un visage une demande de
citoyenneté et eux ils la subissent
cette situation là il ya une dame qui
nous a contacté plusieurs fois au début
de pandémie parce que son conjoint avait
coincé aux états unis pouvaient pas les
voir je pense à cette député fédéral du
npd niki ashton qui nous a dit oui mais
moi j'étais allé voir quelqu'un de
malade en grèce oui j'ai une proche
oui je comprends mais il ya combien de
gens ici qui n'ont pas pu assister aux
funérailles ou aux derniers nomades de 1
être cher alors il semble y avoir quand
même un certain deux poids deux mesures
où on trouve des excuses à nos élus
alors que la population sans que très
très peu de tolérance actuellement on va
terminer ce qui reste peu de temps sur
le fameux mille dollars en partie un
voyage recevez mille dollars
on sait qu'ils sauraient plus nuancé et
plus compliqué que actuellement
gouvernement libéral de monsieur trudeau
d'écouter ce n'est pas sale intentions
on va changer les choses mais elle en
avez vous on va y aller rapidement pour
faire un petit tour de table
il assume 30 avez vous l'impression
qu'on va être capable de corriger la
perception dans le gouvernement trudeau
là dessus ça va être un peu difficile
mais on va je pense qu'ils s'en sortent
bien parce qu'ils ont tout de suite
réagi immédiatement en semaine mais il
faut quand même garder allait à l'esprit
que ça s'adresse seulement aux
travailleurs un refus un retraité qui
revient ne peut pas voir ça il faut pas
que vous ayez de congés payés par votre
emploi
il faut pas que le télétravail soit
possible pour vous alors je lui même
malgré tout cela je suis pas certaine
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
qualifie à ce programme le les faits
sauf que cette image en les gens ont eu
l'impression ses sauts elle vous prenez
ça à la légère les règles sanitaires
qu'en plus on vend vous récompenser une
certaine façon qui ça c'est sûr la
perception politique ne sort pas du tout
autour de moi je reviens pas que quand
il ya une rage contre ça ici c'est
injuste quelque part parce que c'est une
brèche
rappelons que dans un premier temps le
gros 90 kg a décidé de dépenser plus que
moins dans cette crise là sous les
applaudissements de tout le monde donc
ça fait partie de sa et rappelons aussi
que c'est pas les québécois qui ont péri
dans le sud qui ont demandé ces 5000 $
là mais il reste que le mal est fait et
on voit quel point on est dans
l'irrationnel
on est dans la vinification et moi ça
make way dernier volet de ces bassins
c'est la cerise sur saône des prix sur
le bord de la plage enfants parce que on
est déjà fâché que les gens soient les
danseuses des en plus qu'ils puissent
avoir accès aux mineurs même s'il ya des
normes nuances à faire comme hélène l'a
dit sur le nombre de personnes qui vont
avoir accès à ce mille dollars quand tu
vois revenir devant savez-vous c'est un
grand plaisir de vous retrouver en 2021
évidemment il des sujets qui récurrent
qui vont revenir souvent vaut sûrement
reparler de coved encore très
régulièrement 2021
mon année encore merci pour ce soir
allez vous aussi pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit
oh